Les contaré un poco
sobre mi charla en TEDxHouston.
A la mañana siguiente de dar esa charla me desperté
con la peor resaca de vulnerabilidad
de toda mi vida.
Y realmente no salí de casa
en tres días.
La primera vez que salí fue para almorzar con una amiga.
Y cuando entré, ella ya estaba en la mesa.
Me senté y me dijo:
"Dios, estás horrible".
Y dije: "Gracias así me siento.
Ya no funciono".
Y preguntó: "¿Pero qué pasa?"
Y contesté: "Acabo de decir a
500 personas
que me hice investigadora
para sortear la vulnerabilidad.
Y que ser vulnerable
resulta, según mis datos,
absolutamente esencial
a toda vida bien intencionada,
dije a estas 500 personas
que tuve una crisis.
Tenía una diapositiva donde se leía "Crisis".
¿Pero en qué momento se me ocurrió que fuese una buena idea?
(Risas)
Y ella dijo: "Vi tu charla transmitida en vivo.
En verdad no eras tú.
Era un poco diferente a lo que sueles hacer.
Pero fue genial".
Y le dije:
"Esto no puede pasar.
YouTube, se está difundiendo en YouTube.
Estamos hablando de 600 ó 700 personas..."
(Risas)
Y me contestó: "Bueno, creo que ya es demasiado tarde".
Y le dije: "Déjame preguntarte algo".
Y ella: "Sí".
Y yo: "¿Te acuerdas cuando estábamos en la universidad
ese tiempo realmente salvaje y un poco tonto?"
Y ella: "Sí".
Y yo: "¿Recuerdas cuando dejamos un mensaje terrible
en el contestador de nuestros exnovios?
¿Y tuvimos que entrar en el dormitorio
y luego borrar la cinta?"
(Risas)
Y ella: "Eh... no".
Así que, por supuesto, lo único que se me ocurrió decir en ese momento fue,
"Sí, yo tampoco.
Eso... yo tampoco".
Y pienso para mis adentros,
"Brene, ¿pero qué haces? ¿qué haces?
¿Por qué sacas esto a colación? ¿Has perdido la cabeza?
Tus hermanas serían perfectas para esto".
Así que alcé la mirada y ella dijo,
"¿De verdad intentarás
robar el video
antes de difundirlo en YouTube?"
Y yo dije: "Sí, lo estoy pensando".
(Risas)
Ella: "Eres el peor ejemplo de vulnerabilidad".
Y entonces la miré y le dije algo
que en ese momento lo consideré un poco dramático,
pero que terminó siendo más profético que dramático.
Le dije:
"y si 500 se convierten en 1000
ó 2000,
mi vida ha llegado a su fin".
(Risas)
Y no tenía ningún plan de contingencia para cuatro millones.
Y mi vida llegaría a su fin cuando eso sucediera.
Y tal vez la parte más difícil de una vida que termina
es que he aprendido algo duro sobre mí,
y es que,
por mucho que yo me frustrara
por no ser capaz de impedir mi trabajo al mundo,
había una parte de mí que trabaja intensamente
en un perfil bajo,
para pasar desapercibida.
Pero quiero hablar de lo que aprendí.
Hay dos cosas que aprendí en el último año.
La primera es que
vulnerabilidad no es debilidad.
Y ese mito
es profundamente peligroso.
Déjeme preguntarles con sinceridad
y les advertiré,
estoy formada como terapeuta,
así que puedo esperar su incomodidad,
así que si alzaran la mano sería estupendo.
¿Cuántos de Uds., con sinceridad,
al pensar en hacer algo vulnerable
o decir algo vulnerable,
piensan, "Dios, la debilidad de la vulnerabilidad. ¿Es esto debilidad?"
¿Cuántos piensan que vulnerabilidad y debilidad son sinónimos?
La mayoría de las personas.
Permítanme una pregunta:
Esta semana en TED,
¿Cuántos, al percibir vulnerabilidad aquí,
pensaron que era pura valentía?
La vulnerabilidad no es debilidad.
Defino vulnerabilidad
como riesgo emocional,
exposición, incertidumbre.
Alimenta nuestra vida cotidiana.
Y he llegado al convencimiento,
son 12 años investigando sobre el tema,
que la vulnerabilidad
es la medida más precisa
de valentía.
Ser vulnerables, dejarnos ver
para ser sinceros.
Una de las cosas raras que sucedieron
tras la explosión de TED,
es que tengo muchas ofertas para impartir conferencias en todo el país,
desde escuelas y asociaciones de padres
hasta empresas de la lista Fortune 500.
Y muchas de las llamadas se desarrollaron así,
"Dra. Brown. Nos encantó la charla en TED.
Nos gustaría que viniera para hablarnos.
Le agradeceríamos
si no menciona vulnerabilidad o vergüenza".
(Risas)
¿De qué les gustaría que hablara?
Hay tres grandes respuestas.
Para ser honesto con uno mismo, sobre todo del sector empresarial:
innovación, creatividad
y cambio.
Así que déjenme mirar en las actas
para decir:
la vulnerabilidad es el lugar donde nace
la innovación, la creatividad y el cambio.
(Aplausos)
Crear es hacer algo
que nunca antes existió.
No hay nada más vulnerable que eso.
La adaptabilidad a los cambios
tiene que ver con la vulnerabilidad.
Lo segundo,
para entender en realidad, finalmente,
la relación entre la vulnerabilidad y el coraje.
Lo segundo que aprendí es:
tenemos que hablar sobre la vergüenza.
Y les seré muy sincera.
Cuando me convertí en "investigadora de vulnerabilidad"
y esto se convirtió en el foco, por la charla en TED,
y no bromeo.
Les pondré un ejemplo.
Hace tres meses, estaba en una tienda de deportes
comprando gafas y canilleras
y todas las cosas que los padres compran en tiendas de deportes.
A un centenar de metros de distancia, esto es lo que escuché:
"La vulnerabilidad de TED. La vulnerabilidad de TED".
(Risas)
Soy una tejana de quinta generación.
Nuestro lema familiar es "Bloquear y cargar".
No soy investigadora nata de la vulnerabilidad.
Así es que yo
simplemente seguí caminando, ella pisándome los talones.
(Risas)
Y luego escucho, "La vulnerabilidad de TED"
Me doy la vuelta y digo, "Hola".
Ella ya aquí mismo y dice:
"Ud. es la investigadora de la vergüenza que tuvo una crisis".
(Risas)
En este punto
los padres hacen como si se sacaran a sus hijos de encima.
¡Miran a otro lado!
Y me siento tan agotada en ese momento de mi vida,
que la miro y digo en realidad,
"Fue un maldito despertar espiritual".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y ella mira hacia atrás y hace esto,
"Lo sé".
Y continuó:
"Vimos la charla de TED en mi club de lectura.
Luego leí su libro
y nos hemos cambiado de nombre
"Las chicas en crisis".
Y dijo: "Nuestro lema es:
nos derrumbamos y es fantástico".
(Risas)
Pueden imaginar
lo que es para mí en una reunión de departamento.
Así es que cuando me convertí en Vulnerabilidad TED,
a modo de personaje de acción,
como la Barbie Ninja, pero yo como Vulnerabilidad TED,
pensé, voy a sacarme esto de la vergüenza de encima,
porque ya pasé seis años estudiando la vergüenza
antes de haber empezado a escribir y hablar sobre vulnerabilidad.
Y pensé que, gracias a Dios, porque la vergüenza es este tema horrible,
del que nadie quiere hablar.
Es la mejor manera de que la gente se cierre en banda.
"¿A qué te dedicas?" "Estudio la vergüenza". "Oh".
(Risas)
Y te estoy viendo.
Pero para sobrevivir este año que pasó,
me acordaba de una regla de oro,
no es una regla de investigación,
sino un imperativo moral
de mi educación...
tienes que bailar con el único que te sepa llevar.
Y no aprendí sobre vulnerabilidad
y coraje, creatividad e innovación
del estudio de vulnerabilidad.
Aprendí de estas cosas
al estudiar la vergüenza.
Y por eso quiero que nos adentremos hacia
la vergüenza.
Los seguidores de Jung denominan a la vergüenza
los pantanos del alma.
Y vamos a adentrarnos allí.
Y el objetivo no es entrar
para construir una casa y vivir allí.
Se trata de ponerse botas de agua
atravesarla y encontrar el camino.
He aquí el porqué.
Hemos oído la llamada más convincente
de tener una conversación en este país,
y pienso de forma global,
en torno a la raza, ¿verdad?
¿Sí? Lo hemos oído.
¿Sí?
No se puede tener esa conversación sin vergüenza,
porque tampoco se puede hablar sobre raza sin hablar de privilegios.
Y cuando la gente empieza a hablar de privilegios,
se paraliza por vergüenza.
Hemos escuchado una solución simple y brillante
para no matar a la gente en el quirófano,
teniendo una lista de verificación.
No se puede solucionar ese problema sin abordar la vergüenza,
porque cuando se enseña cómo suturar,
también se enseña cómo suturar su autoestima
siendo todopoderoso.
Y todos esos todopoderosos no necesitan listas de verificación.
Y me escribí el nombre de este miembro de TED
para no equivocarme.
Mishkin Ingawale,
Espero haberlo hecho bien.
(Aplausos)
Vi aquí a compañeros de TED el primer día.
Y uno de ellos se paró y explicó
qué le llevó a crear
una tecnología para detectar la anemia
porque la gente moría innecesariamente.
Y dijo: "Vi la necesidad.
Así, ¿qué creen que hice? Yo lo desarrollé".
Y todos irrumpieron en aplausos, diciendo "¡Sí!"
Y entonces dijo: "Y no funcionó.
Entonces lo probé 32 veces más,
hasta que funcionó.
¿Saben cuál es el gran secreto de TED?
No veo la hora de decirlo.
Creo que ya lo estoy haciendo.
(Risas)
Es como la conferencia del fracaso.
No, de verdad.
(Aplausos)
¿Saben por qué este lugar es increíble?
Porque muy pocas personas aquí,
tienen miedo al fracaso.
Y nadie que yo haya visto hasta ahora subido a este escenario, no ha fracasado.
He fracasado miserablemente muchas veces.
No creo que el mundo lo considere
una vergüenza.
Una gran cita me salvó el año pasado.
Es de Theodore Roosevelt.
Muchas personas la aluden como la cita del "Hombre en el ruedo".
Y reza más o menos así.
"No importan las críticas.
Ni aquellos que muestran
cómo aquellos que hicieron algo podrían haberlo hecho mejor
y cómo yerran y dan un traspié tras otro.
El reconocimiento pertenece al hombre que está en el ruedo
con el rostro manchado
de polvo, sudor y sangre.
Pero cuando está en el ruedo,
en el mejor de los casos gana,
y en el peor, pierde,
pero cuando falla, cuando pierde,
lo hace con gran osadía".
Y de eso trata esta conferencia.
De eso va la vida, de atreverse mucho,
de estar en el ruedo.
Cuando vamos a entrar al ruedo y tenemos la mano en la puerta,
y pensamos: "Entraré y lo intentaré",
la vergüenza es el fantasma
que dice: "Uh, uh.
¡No eres lo suficientemente bueno!
Nunca terminaste el master. Te dejó tu esposa.
Sé que tu padre realmente no estaba en Luxemburgo,
estaba en Sing Sing.
Sé las cosas que te sucedieron de niño.
Sé que no crees que seas lo suficientemente apuesto
o lo suficientemente inteligente o talentoso o lo suficientemente vigoroso.
Sé que tu padre nunca te prestó atención, incluso al convertirte en director de finanzas".
La vergüenza es eso.
Y si podemos acallarla, seguir
y decir: "Lo haré",
alzamos la mirada y el crítico que vemos
señalándonos y riéndose,
es el 99 % de las veces ¿quién?
Nosotros mismos.
La vergüenza grava dos grandes cintas.
"Nunca lo suficientemente bueno"
y, si puedes hablar de eso,
"¿Quién te crees que eres?"
Lo que se debe entender sobre la vergüenza es que no es culpa.
La vergüenza está centrada en uno mismo, la culpa en el comportamiento.
La vergüenza es "soy malo".
La culpa es "Hice algo mal".
¿Cuántos de Uds.,
si hicieron algo que fue doloroso para mí,
estarían dispuestos a decir: "Lo siento. He cometido un error"?
¿Cuántos de Uds. estarían dispuestos a decirlo?
La culpa: lo siento. He cometido un error.
Vergüenza: Lo siento. Yo soy un error.
Hay una gran diferencia entre la vergüenza y la culpa.
Y esto es lo que necesitan saber.
La vergüenza está muy correlacionada
con adicción, depresión, violencia, agresión,
intimidación, suicidio y trastornos alimentarios.
Y además debemos saber algo más.
La culpa está inversamente correlacionada con esas cosas.
La capacidad de retener algo que hemos hecho o dejado de hacer
en contra de lo que queremos ser
es increíblemente adaptable.
Es incómodo, pero es adaptable.
Otra cosa que deben saber acerca de la vergüenza
es que está absolutamente organizada por género.
Si la vergüenza me inunda e inunda a Chris,
nos sentiremos igual.
Todo el mundo aquí conoce la inundación tibia de la vergüenza.
Estamos bastante seguros de que las únicas personas que no experimentan vergüenza
son quienes no tienen capacidad
para la conexión o la empatía.
Lo que significa: sí, tengo un poco de vergüenza;
no, no soy un sociópata.
Así que optaré por, sí, tenemos un poco de vergüenza.
La vergüenza la sienten igual hombres y mujeres,
pero se organiza por género.
Para las mujeres,
el mejor ejemplo que puedo darles
es Enjoli
el anuncio publicitario:
"Puedo poner la lavadora,
preparar los almuerzos, dar los besos
y estar en el trabajo a las 8:55.
Puedo traer a casa carne, freírla en la sartén
y hacer que siempre recuerdes que eres un hombre".
Para las mujeres, la vergüenza es hacerlo todo,
hacerlo perfectamente
y nunca dejar que te vean sudar.
No sé la cantidad de perfume que vendió ese anuncio,
pero les garantizo,
que movió una gran cantidad de antidepresivos y ansiolíticos.
(Risas)
La vergüenza, para las mujeres, es esta red
de expectativas contradictorias y competencias imposibles de obtener
relacionadas con lo se supone que debemos ser.
Y es una camisa de fuerza.
Para los hombres,
la vergüenza no es un montón de expectativas contradictorias y conflictivas.
La vergüenza es una,
no ser percibido ¿como qué?
Débil.
No entrevisté a hombres durante los primeros cuatro años de mi estudio.
Y no fue hasta que un hombre me miró un día después de la firma de libros,
y dijo: "Me encanta lo que tiene que decir sobre la vergüenza,
me pregunto por qué no mencionó a los hombres".
Y dije: "No estudio a los hombres".
Y él: "Eso es práctico".
(Risas)
Y yo: "¿Por qué?"
Y él: "Porque Ud. dice que para llegar
a contar nuestra historia,
debemos ser vulnerables.
Pero, ¿ve los libros que acaba de firmar
para mi esposa y mis tres hijas?"
Y yo: "Sí".
"Ellas prefieren que muera sobre mi caballo blanco
a verme fracasar.
Cuando conseguimos ser vulnerables
tenemos que salir como podemos de ese lío.
Y no me diga Ud.
que esto se debe a los chicos, los entrenadores y los papás,
porque las mujeres en mi vida son mucho más duras conmigo que cualquier otra persona".
Así que empecé a entrevistar a hombres
y hacer preguntas.
Y lo que he aprendido es lo siguiente:
muéstrenme a una mujer que realmente pueda sentarse con un hombre
con vulnerabilidad y miedo,
les mostraré a una mujer que ha hecho un trabajo increíble.
Muéstrenme a un hombre que pueda sentarse con una mujer
que no da más,
que ya no puede hacerlo todo,
y la primera respuesta de él no es,
"He vaciado el lavavajillas"
lo que realmente hace es escuchar,
porque eso es todo lo que necesitamos...
Les mostraré a un hombre que ha hecho un gran trabajo.
La vergüenza es una epidemia en nuestra cultura.
Y para salir de ella,
para encontrar el camino de vuelta,
tenemos que entender cómo nos afecta
y cómo afecta nuestra paternidad,
cómo trabajamos, cómo nos buscamos el uno al otro.
Muy rápidamente, algo breve sobre la investigación de Mahalik del Boston College.
Él preguntaba qué deben hacer las mujeres para ajustarse a las normas femeninas.
Las 10 respuestas más frecuentes en este país:
ser bonita, delgada, modesta
y recurrir siempre a la apariencia.
Cuando preguntó sobre los hombres,
¿qué creen que los hombres en este país tienen que hacer
para ajustarse a las normas masculinas?
Las respuestas fueron:
mostrar siempre control emocional, el trabajo es lo primero,
lograr estatus social y uso de la violencia.
Si vamos a reencontrarnos el uno al otro,
tenemos que entender y conocer la empatía,
porque la empatía es el antídoto para la vergüenza.
Si ponemos la vergüenza en una placa de Petri,
se necesitan tres cosas para crecer de forma exponencial:
secretismo, silencio y juicio.
Si se pone la misma cantidad de vergüenza en una placa de Petri y se rocía con empatía,
no puede sobrevivir.
Las dos palabras más poderosas cuando estamos en lucha:
Yo también.
Y, les dejo este pensamiento.
Si vamos a reencontrar el camino
que nos una,
deberemos transitar la vulnerabilidad.
Y sé que es muy seductor permanecer fuera del ruedo,
porque creo que es lo que hice toda mi vida,
y pienso para mis adentros,
iré allá y propinaré una buena patada
cuando esté acorazada y sea perfecta.
Y eso es seductor.
Pero la verdad es que nunca sucede.
E incluso si has llegado a ser tan perfecto
y estar bien acorazado
cuando logres la meta,
no será eso lo que querrás ver.
Queremos que tú entres.
Queremos estar contigo y frente a ti.
Y sólo queremos,
para nosotros y para los nuestros
y para la gente con la que trabajamos,
una gran osadía.
Así que muchas gracias a todos. Realmente lo agradezco.
(Aplausos)